This episode is brought to you by Lloyds, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down to two important elements, aspiration and action. And a classic example of this from British history, the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who between them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it, Tom? A great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism.
本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyds）赞助播出，该银行两百五十多年来一直支持着英国人的雄心壮志。说起来，历史上的每一个王朝归根结底都离不开两个重要因素：抱负与行动。英国历史上有一个经典的例子，那就是威塞克斯王朝的崛起，阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同建立了英格兰联合王国。没错，这是一个伟大的故事，对吧，汤姆？我认为这对任何人来说都是一堂关于领导力的好课。所以，阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人们将理想主义与实用主义结合在了一起。
They're brilliant at alliances. They're brilliant at managing power. They're brilliance, of course, at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership. And, of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyds to be ready. when you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and new life chapters, backed by generations
他们擅长结盟，擅长驾驭权力。当然，他们也擅长理财，这是政治领导力的关键部分。当然，我们都在享受着他们的智慧和远见所带来的成果。当您需要做出下一个重大决策时，您可以信赖劳埃德银行，我们随时准备为您提供支持。因为从新企业到新家园，再到人生的新篇章，在几代人的希望与雄心支持下，
of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust Lloyds to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's internal customer data from March 26. AI was supposed to take over the parts of the job you hate. Turns out, it made your job even harder. Instead of doing the work, it gave you homework. Service Now's AI specialists get work done from start to finish. Cases get resolved, loops get closed. With ServiceNow, you can do the parts of your job you're best at and delegate the rest. To put AI to work for people, visit servicenow.com. Soon, as the Athenians crossed deeper into No Man's Land, the first arrows began to hiss down upon them. Then, raising the monstrous weight of their shields to protect their chests, the hoplites
汤姆，您一定能明白为什么一千四百万客户信任劳埃德银行，并让我们帮助他们实现梦想。数据基于劳埃德银行截至3月26日的内部客户数据。人工智能本应接管您讨厌的工作部分，结果却让您的工作变得更加困难。它没有帮您完成工作，反而给您布置了家庭作业。ServiceNow的人工智能专家能从头到尾帮您搞定工作。案件得以解决，流程得以闭环。有了ServiceNow，您可以专注于自己最擅长的工作，将其他任务委派出去。想要让人工智能真正为人类服务，请访问servicenow.com。很快，随着雅典人深入无人区，第一批箭雨开始呼啸而下。随后，重装步兵们举起沉重的盾牌护住胸口，
did at last begin to run. Simultaneously, as though the phalanx were some ferocious, cornered creature stiffening its bristles as it turns to face its foe, those in the front three ranks lowered and aimed their spears in preparation for the coming collision. By now, with some 150 yards still to travel, a storm cloud of arrows and slingshot was breaking over them, thudding into their shields, bouncing off their helmets, striking the odd hoplight in the thigh or through the throat. But still the Athenians, braving the black rain, only quickened their pace. Those of the enemy directly in their path had already begun scrabbling to erect wicker defences, as they realized to their horror, that the wall of shields and iron-tipped spears,
终于开始奔跑。与此同时，方阵就像一只被逼入绝境、竖起鬃毛准备迎敌的凶猛野兽，前三排的士兵压低并瞄准了长矛，为即将到来的碰撞做准备。此时，距离还有约150码，箭雨和投石如风暴般向他们袭来，重重地砸在盾牌上，从头盔上弹开，偶尔有重装步兵的大腿或喉咙被击中。但雅典人冒着黑色的箭雨，只是加快了步伐。敌军中挡在他们前进道路上的人已经开始手忙脚乱地架设柳条防御工事，因为他们惊恐地意识到，那堵由盾牌和铁尖长矛组成的墙，
far from providing easy pickings for their bowmen, as they had at first imagined, was not going to be halted. A hundred yards, fifty, twenty, ten. Then as the Athenians' war cry, a terrifying allulation rose even above the thundering of their feet upon the dry earth, the cacophony of clattering metal, and the screams of the panic-stricken enemy, the phalanx crunched into the Persian lines. What a dramatic moment that is. That is the moment when the Athenian phalanx charges and smashes into the ranks of the invading Persians at the Battle of Marathon as narrated by friend of the show Dan Brown in his book Persian Fire. So rude.
远非他们最初想象的那样是弓箭手的活靶子，而是根本无法被阻挡。一百码，五十，二十，十。接着，当雅典人的战吼声——一种恐怖的呼喊声——盖过了他们在大地上奔跑的雷鸣声、金属碰撞的嘈杂声以及敌军惊恐的尖叫声时，方阵狠狠地撞进了波斯人的阵线。那是一个多么戏剧性的时刻。正如节目好友丹·布朗在他的著作《波斯之火》中所讲述的那样，那是雅典方阵在马拉松战役中冲锋并粉碎入侵波斯军队的时刻。太粗鲁了。
We are in the late summer of 490 BC. Everything hangs in the balance and who better to tell the story than the man who wrote those words. Dan Brown himself. Tom Holland is with us on the podcast. So Tom, we advertised this at the end of the previous episode where we did the build-up to the Battle of Marathon, the war between the Persians and the Greeks. We advertise this as one of the great showdowns, not just in ancient history, but in all history. It's a battle that proved a template for so many clashes to come, seen even today, especially, I think, in America, by historians who teach at military academies. We'll often say it's the great titanic showdown between democracy and despotism. So you've got the Athenians on one side and on the other. You have the most powerful man on earth, Darias, the great the king of kings, the Shah of Shars, the emperor of Persia. Why is this battle so celebrated? Well, I think there are a number of reasons.
我们现在处于公元前490年的夏末。一切都悬于一线，还有谁比写下这些文字的人更适合讲述这个故事呢？正是丹·布朗本人。汤姆·霍兰也来到了我们的播客。汤姆，我们在上一集结尾预告过，当时我们讲述了马拉松战役的准备阶段，即波斯与希腊之间的战争。我们将其宣传为古代史上，乃至整个人类历史上最伟大的对决之一。这场战役为后来的许多冲突提供了模板，即使在今天，特别是在美国，那些在军事学院任教的历史学家们也经常提到它。他们常说，这是民主与专制之间伟大的泰坦式对决。所以，一边是雅典人，另一边是地球上最有权势的人——万王之王、众王之王、波斯帝国皇帝大流士。为什么这场战役如此受推崇？嗯，我认为有几个原因。
The first is that, I mean, it is the first battle in European history that we can kind of reconstruct. So that is courtesy of Herodotus, who recounts it in considerable detail. There are gaps, and so there are various interpretations of the battle, and the interpretation you're going to hear today is mine. But I think on the fundamentals, people are pretty agreed what happened. And so that is a first. I think also it has always been seen as one of history's most decisive battles. It really matters who wins in this clash.
首先，它是欧洲历史上第一场我们可以进行某种程度还原的战役。这要归功于希罗多德，他在书中对此进行了相当详细的叙述。虽然存在一些空白，因此对战役有各种解读，而你们今天听到的解读是我的版本。但我认为在基本事实上，人们的看法相当一致。所以这是一个首例。我认为它也一直被视为历史上最具决定性的战役之一。在这场冲突中，谁获胜至关重要。
and this begins with the Athenians themselves who, and it's a massive spoiler alert here, the Athenians win it. They've been massively outnumbered. They're facing an enemy that has never been defeated by Greeks before, but they've done it and they've saved Greece. And decades, centuries, maybe even millennia, I mean, Greeks still go on about it. This sense that they have, they have saved freedom is something that they never leave alone. And perhaps it's a little bit like the British going on about the Battle of Britain. There's a slight kind of similar quality to that, I think. But it's not just the Greeks who have said that the Battle of Marathon was decisive. So this is John Stuart Mill in the 19th century. The Battle of Marathon, he wrote, even as an event in English history,
这要从雅典人自己说起，这里有一个巨大的剧透：雅典人赢了。他们当时在人数上处于绝对劣势。他们面对的是一支从未被希腊人击败过的敌军，但他们做到了，他们拯救了希腊。几十年来，几个世纪，甚至几千年，希腊人一直在谈论这件事。他们拯救了自由的这种信念，是他们从未放下过的。也许这有点像英国人一直在谈论不列颠战役。我认为两者之间有一种微妙的相似之处。但不仅仅是希腊人认为马拉松战役具有决定性。这是19世纪的约翰·斯图尔特·密尔所写的：马拉松战役，即使作为英国历史上的一个事件，
is more important than the Battle of Hastings. If the issue of that day had been different, the Britons and the Saxons might still have been wandering in the woods. And what he means by that is that the Battle of Marathon is the battle that enabled the West to become the West. It enabled Europe to become properly European. And by extension, it's the triumph of liberty over slavery and of democracy over despotism, as you said. But is it not the case that had the persons won the Battle of Marathon people in Britain would have been wearing trousers much earlier than the end of war? And I think the the notion of it being the victory of freedom is something that, as you say, it's still current today, I think particularly, as you said, in right-wing circles, perhaps in America.
也比黑斯廷斯战役更重要。如果那一天的结果不同，不列颠人和撒克逊人可能至今还在森林里游荡。他的意思是，马拉松战役是使西方成为西方、使欧洲真正成为欧洲的战役。推而广之，正如你所说，这是自由战胜奴役、民主战胜专制的胜利。但如果波斯人赢得了马拉松战役，英国人会不会比战后更早穿上裤子呢？我认为关于它是自由胜利的观念，正如你所说，在今天依然流行，特别是在美国的右翼圈子里。
But it's not just people on the right who have celebrated marathon. So Byron back in the beginning of the 19th century, who would end up dying for freedom, dying for Greece, kind of the prototype of the supporter of the struggle for self-determination. He visited the plane of marathon at a time when Greece was being ruled by the Ottomans, and he then wrote kind of famous lines, The mountains look on marathon, and marathon looks on the sea, and musing there an hour alone, I dreamed that Greece might still be free. For standing on the Persian's grave, I could not deem myself a slave.
但不仅仅是右翼人士在赞美马拉松。19世纪初的拜伦，最终为自由而死，为希腊而死，他可以说是支持民族自决斗争的先驱。他在希腊被奥斯曼帝国统治时期访问了马拉松平原，并写下了著名的诗句：“群山俯瞰马拉松，马拉松俯瞰大海；在那儿独自沉思一小时，我梦想着希腊或许仍能自由。因为站在波斯人的坟墓上，我无法认为自己是奴隶。”
So the question of whether it really was decisive, whether it really was the triumph over something called the West, over something called the East of freedom over despotism. I mean, these important questions, and we will come to them in due course. But I think more pressing is the details of the battle itself, the kind of incredible heart-stopping drama of this incredible clash. So before we come to that, a reminder of what we covered in our previous episode. So Darius is the king of Persia, the king of kings,
所以，关于它是否真的具有决定性，是否真的是所谓的西方战胜了东方、自由战胜了专制，这些都是重要的问题，我们将在适当的时候讨论。但我认为更紧迫的是战役本身的细节，这场不可思议的冲突中那种令人心跳停止的戏剧性。在进入正题之前，先回顾一下我们在上一集中涵盖的内容。大流士是波斯国王，万王之王，
and he rules this immense empire, which now stretches from Macedon, from the foothills of Mount Olympus, all the way to the Indus. Darius is committed to having his vengeance on the Athenians, who had backed a revolt against Persian rule in Ionia, which is on the far side of the Aegean from Greece, so what is now Turkey? Darius had sent a naval expedition commanded by his nephew, a guy called Artafernes,
他统治着这个庞大的帝国，现在从马其顿、奥林匹斯山的脚下，一直延伸到印度河。大流士决心向雅典人复仇，因为他们支持了爱奥尼亚地区反抗波斯统治的起义，该地区位于希腊爱琴海的另一侧，也就是现在的土耳其。大流士派遣了一支由他的侄子阿塔弗内斯指挥的海军远征队，
and by Daitis, who is a mead, who specialises in Greek affairs. He knows how to fight them, but he also knows how to negotiate with them, and he's probably the guy who's really in command. The Persian task force has sailed across the Aegean. It has already sacked the city of Eretria, which had joined Athens in attacking Darius's empire, and now Eretria has been burnt to the ground,
以及达提斯，他是一位米底人，专门负责希腊事务。他知道如何与他们作战，也知道如何与他们谈判，他很可能才是真正的指挥官。波斯特遣部队已经横渡了爱琴海。它已经洗劫了曾加入雅典攻击大流士帝国的埃雷特里亚城，现在埃雷特里亚已被夷为平地，
its people have been taken as slaves, and it is the turn of Athens. But the task force, as it sails down the coastline of Attica, is heading not directly for, for Athens itself, but for the Bay of Marathon. And the reason for that, I think, is that Datis does not wish to attempt an opposed landing. That's always the most kind of difficult task for an amphibious force. And if he heads for Phelerum, which is the port that serves Athens, then obviously that
其人民被掳为奴，现在轮到雅典了。但特遣部队在沿着阿提卡海岸航行时，并没有直接驶向雅典，而是驶向了马拉松湾。我认为原因在于，达提斯不想尝试进行一场有抵抗的登陆。对于两栖部队来说，这总是最困难的任务。如果他驶向雅典的港口法勒隆，那么显然
would be inevitable. That's what he would be facing. So for people who have only a vague sense of the geography of Attica, which is the kind of area of land dominated by Athens. If you think of it as the kind of the head of a horse which is reaching down to drink from a trough, sticking out from mainland Greece, marathon lies on the opposite eastern side of that peninsula from Athens. Right.
那是不可避免的。那将是他所面临的局面。所以对于那些对阿提卡地理只有模糊概念的人来说，阿提卡是雅典统治的区域。如果你把它想象成一个马头，正低头从槽里喝水，从希腊大陆伸出来，马拉松就位于那个半岛与雅典相对的东侧。没错。
And so there are good reasons for the Persian Task Force to head there. There's a very long beach onto which the Persian ships can be hauled up. There's a very long scimitar-shaped plane on which the Persians can make their base. and which crucially is perfect for the operation of their cavalry. And also from Marathon, it is possible to get to Athens. So there's a road which leads from the south of the plain up the foothills. It bifocates and one road goes inland. One road goes along the coast around the mountains that separate Marathon from Athens.
所以波斯特遣部队前往那里是有充分理由的。那里有一片很长的海滩，波斯船只可以拖上岸。那里有一片长长的弯刀形平原，波斯人可以在那里建立基地，而且至关重要的是，这非常适合他们的骑兵作战。此外，从马拉松出发，是有可能到达雅典的。有一条路从平原南部通往山脚，它分叉开来，一条路通往内陆，另一条路沿着海岸绕过将马拉松与雅典隔开的山脉。
And it means that if the Persians can get onto that road, then they will be able to march on Athens without too much trouble. Now, what if the Athenians come out of Athens and advance to Marathon to meet with the Persians in battle? Well, the Persians are very confident if that happens that they will have the victory. As we said, they're strong in cavalry. The Greeks who rely entirely on heavy infantry have no cavalry at all. Marathon as a flat plane is ideally suited to the operation of cavalry, and not once in 50 years of Greco-Persian warfare has a Greek army been able to defeat the Persians in pitched battle. So the Persians have every reason to be confident. So why would the Athenians do
这意味着如果波斯人能走上那条路，他们就能毫无阻碍地向雅典进军。那么，如果雅典人走出雅典，前往马拉松与波斯人交战会怎样呢？嗯，波斯人非常有信心，如果发生这种情况，他们会获胜。正如我们所说，他们骑兵强大。完全依赖重装步兵的希腊人根本没有骑兵。马拉松作为一片平原，非常适合骑兵作战，而且在50年的希腊-波斯战争中，希腊军队从未能在正面战场上击败波斯人。所以波斯人有充分的理由自信。那么雅典人为什么要
that when they could stay? Surely if you're an Athenian commander, the obvious thing to do is to say, why don't we stay, where don't we wait for the Persians to come, bring them on, we'll stay in our city and withstand a siege and eventually they'll go home. Well, if they do that, then the Persians are confident as well that they will win because they are almost certain that the city will end up being portrayed. The Persians have a lot of experience of dealing with the Greeks. They know that there are very fractious people given to kind of violent class tensions, rivalries among their leading men, all kinds of things like that. And so it's very easy for the Persians to foster tensions. And it's already worked with Eretria, the city that they have just sacked, because that
那样做呢？如果他们可以留守？如果你是雅典指挥官，显而易见的事情是说，为什么我们不留下来，为什么不等待波斯人过来，引诱他们，我们留在城里抵御围攻，最终他们会回家。嗯，如果他们那样做，波斯人也相信他们会赢，因为他们几乎肯定这座城市最终会被出卖。波斯人处理希腊人的经验非常丰富。他们知道希腊人是一个非常难以驾驭的民族，容易产生激烈的阶级矛盾、领导人之间的竞争等等。所以波斯人很容易煽动紧张局势。这在埃雷特里亚已经奏效了，他们刚刚洗劫了那座城市，因为那座
city had been betrayed by two of the leading aristocrats. The gates had been opened. And so there is no reason to think that the same dirty tricks wouldn't work in Athens. And evidence of the fact that there are Athenians who are willing to work with the Persians is there in the form of the man who has actually led them to Marathon because he is an Athenian and he is the former Tyrannos, the former autocratic strongman of the city, this guy called Hippias who had been expelled back in 510 and he's now 80 years old and he hasn't been back to his native city for two decades now. he'd gone and taken refuge with the local Persian governor. The governor had demanded the Athenians take him back, and they had said no way.
城市被两名主要的贵族出卖了。城门被打开了。所以没有理由认为同样的卑劣手段在雅典行不通。有证据表明，确实有雅典人愿意与波斯人合作，那就是带领他们来到马拉松的那个人，因为他是一个雅典人，是该市的前僭主、前独裁强人，这个叫希庇亚斯的人，他在公元前510年被驱逐，现在已经80岁了，他已经二十年没有回到他的故乡了。他去投靠了当地的波斯总督。总督要求雅典人接纳他，但他们拒绝了。
Hippias does not see himself as a traitor. He's convinced that the only way that Athens can be saved is if the Athenians can be brought to submit to the Persians. And so he sees himself as the person who's the kind of ideal middleman. And actually the night before the Persian fleet set sail for Marathon, he'd try to, dreams that he's sleeping with his mother. And this is a sign that he is going to be reunited with his homeland. I mean, I'm not sure Dr. Freud would agree with that interpretation, perhaps, but this is the interpretation that the Greeks give it.
希庇亚斯并不认为自己是叛徒。他坚信，拯救雅典的唯一途径就是让雅典人屈服于波斯人。所以他把自己看作是一个理想的中间人。事实上，在波斯舰队启航前往马拉松的前一天晚上，他梦见自己与母亲同床。这是一个他将与祖国团聚的迹象。嗯，我不确定弗洛伊德博士是否会同意这种解释，但这确实是希腊人给出的解释。
And sure enough, the next day, Hippias is present when the Persian fleet draws up at marathon, the keels of the ships are dragged up onto the sands. Hippias steps down. He is back on attic soil, ready as he sees it to try and bring. the Athenians into the light of the Persian king's favour. Will you talk about the Athenians and the light? So in very Lord of the Rings, Return of the King style,
果然，第二天，当波斯舰队在马拉松靠岸时，希庇亚斯在场，船底被拖上沙滩。希庇亚斯走下船。他回到了阿提卡的土地上，正如他所认为的那样，准备尝试将雅典人带入波斯国王的恩宠之光中。你谈到了雅典人和光。所以，非常有《指环王：王者归来》的风格，
the Athenians, as soon as they've heard the news, as soon as news has reached people on the coast, that the Persians are landing. They've lit a giant beacon, haven't they? A mount Pentelicon. So that's midway between Marathon and Athens to communicate the news. The beacons are lit.
雅典人一听到消息，一旦消息传到海岸上的人们耳中，得知波斯人正在登陆。他们点燃了一个巨大的烽火台，不是吗？在彭特利库斯山上。那是马拉松和雅典之间，用来传递消息。烽火被点燃了。
Athens calls for aid. Great scenes. And presumably, I mean, this is an age of rumour and exaggeration. So there must be the most tremendous rumours and... Yeah, mass panic. Paranoid fantasies about the size of the Persian army. Yeah, these terrifying Asiatic hordes who have landed on the sacred soil of Attica. And even though probably these reports are exaggerated, it is clear from the first reports that the Athenians are going to be significantly outnumbered, maybe two to one, maybe even three to one. We're not entirely sure.
雅典呼吁援助。伟大的场景。而且大概，这是一个谣言和夸张的时代。所以一定有最可怕的谣言和……是的，大规模恐慌。关于波斯军队规模的偏执幻想。是的，这些登陆阿提卡神圣土地的恐怖亚洲部落。即使这些报告可能被夸大了，但从第一份报告中可以清楚地看出，雅典人的人数将大大少于对方，可能是二比一，甚至三比一。我们不太确定。
And so you're right. Of course, there are people who say, this is mad. We can't go out and confront them. We should stay behind our walls. But actually, even before that beacon is lit, the decision has already been taken to go out and confront the invaders in the field. And the man who had pushed this course in the assembly of the democracy and had it voted on and passed as an official resolution of the Athenian people is the city's most proficient campaigner against. the Persians, the city's great Meadrater, as he's called, Miltaiades, because he has fought with and against the Persians. He understands how they work. He understands how their military operations
所以你是对的。当然，有人说，这太疯狂了。我们不能出去面对他们。我们应该留在城墙后面。但实际上，甚至在烽火点燃之前，就已经决定要出去在战场上对抗入侵者了。而在民主议会中推动这一方针并将其投票通过为雅典人民官方决议的人，是该市最精通反波斯运动的人，该市伟大的“米底人克星”，正如他被称为的那样，米尔提阿德斯，因为他曾与波斯人并肩作战，也曾与他们交战。他了解他们的运作方式。他了解他们的军事行动
are conducted. And so his plan, the moment that the Persians have landed at Marathon, which is where Miltes had expected they would land, is to march at top speed to that southern kind of mountain at the southern end of marathon and to block the road that otherwise will enable the Persians to get to Athens from marathon. And if they can get there in time, then they will be able to bottle the Persians up
是如何进行的。所以他的计划，在波斯人登陆马拉松的那一刻——这也是米尔提阿德斯预料他们会登陆的地方——就是以最快的速度向马拉松南端的那座山进军，并封锁那条否则将使波斯人从马拉松到达雅典的道路。如果他们能及时赶到，那么他们就能将波斯人困在
on the plane of marathon and thereby stop the Persian cavalry from taking that road and fanning out across Attica. It's actually a little bit like Harold, wanting to get to Hastings to stop the Norman cavalry from breaking out. It's kind of similar kind of strategy. So the beacon is lit. People see the flame. There's a tremendous scene, isn't they blow this great trumpet?
马拉松平原上，从而阻止波斯骑兵走那条路并散布到整个阿提卡。这实际上有点像哈罗德想要赶到黑斯廷斯去阻止诺曼骑兵突围。这是一种类似的策略。所以烽火点燃了。人们看到了火焰。有一个巨大的场景，他们吹响了这支大号角？
Yeah. They summon men to the mustering ground, which is a sort of exercise ground, which has been dedicated to Apollo. It's outside the city. And Miltiades is just one of ten generals. Yes. So there's a board of ten generals. He's not the Supreme Commander. The Supreme Commander is a guy called Kalimachus, the War Archon. The War Archon. So they've all been elected by public vote. The War Archon, Kalimachus. He's an overall command. But the generals, you have ten of them for each of the kind of the various tribes that the democracy has set up. So Milaides is commander of his tribe. And each of these ten commanders take it in turn to be Kilimachus's subordinate. So to have the kind of overall control. And how many men are we talking about? Probably around 10,000 men.
是的。他们召集人们到集合地，那是一个专门献给阿波罗的训练场。它在城外。米尔提阿德斯只是十位将军之一。是的。所以有一个十人将军委员会。他不是最高指挥官。最高指挥官是一个叫卡利马科斯的人，战争执政官。战争执政官。所以他们都是通过公众投票选出来的。战争执政官卡利马科斯。他拥有最高指挥权。但将军们，你们有十个人，分别代表民主制度建立的各个部落。所以米尔提阿德斯是他部落的指挥官。这十位指挥官轮流担任卡利马科斯的下属。所以拥有某种整体控制权。我们说的是多少人？可能大约一万人。
Okay. And they head off and they have slaves to carry their armor. They have pack animals to carry their rations. and they take one of the two roads that leads from Athens to marathon and probably the coastal road because although it's 26 miles against 22 miles, which is the other road, the other road takes you up into the mountains, so you're much more kind of vulnerable there. And also it would leave the coastal road open to the cavalry. So I'm fairly confident that they take the coastal road.
好的。他们出发了，他们有奴隶携带盔甲。他们有驮畜携带口粮。他们走的是从雅典到马拉松的两条路之一，很可能是沿海公路，因为虽然它是26英里，而另一条路是22英里，但另一条路会带你进入山区，所以你在那里更容易受到攻击。而且它会让沿海公路对骑兵开放。所以我相当肯定他们走的是沿海公路。
And they march a tremendous speed. And Athenians going at a tremendous speed is going to be a theme of this episode. and they arrive at the crest of the hill that overlooks Marathon from the south. And you mentioned Daughter the Rings. This is kind of like the riders of Rowan gazing down at the battlefield of Pelinor Fields. Because what they see, I mean, is terrifying. The bay is black with ships. They can see these ships, you know, arms and provisions and horses being unloaded
他们以惊人的速度行军。而雅典人以惊人的速度行军将成为本集的一个主题。他们到达了从南面俯瞰马拉松的山顶。你提到了《指环王》。这有点像洛汗骑兵凝视着帕兰诺平原的战场。因为他们所看到的，是可怕的。海湾里满是黑色的船只。他们可以看到这些船只，你知道，武器、补给和马匹正在被卸下，
across this kind of great seaweed matted bank beach. And presumably there are already Persian outriders kind of raising dust across the plane, reconnoitering the limits of the plane. And it's these horsemen who most terrify the Athenians because they know that they will be very, very vulnerable to attack by horsemen. They are kind of lumbering heavy infantry. They would be sitting ducks if they were caught in the open by the horse. Just a question, Athenians have no horsemen at all?
穿过这片巨大的海藻覆盖的海滩。而且大概已经有波斯前哨骑兵在平原上扬起尘土，侦察平原的边界。正是这些骑兵最让雅典人感到恐惧，因为他们知道他们非常容易受到骑兵的攻击。他们是那种笨重的重装步兵。如果他们在开阔地被骑兵抓住，他们将成为活靶子。只是一个问题，雅典人根本没有骑兵吗？
No, not really, because their force and their power comes from infantry. So even those who are very wealthy will generally fight on foot. And that kind of determines their strategy. Basically, they have to hold their defensive position. They cannot afford to go down into the plane because otherwise it really would be curtains. But actually, they don't need to leave the heights because they've arrived in time to block any Persian advance on Athens. And so to that extent, Mildesai's plan has worked. And there is, there's a shrine to Heracles on the Heights, which has a kind of a grove in front of it, which provides a degree of screening. And so they, they fortify the temple of Heracles. They set up their lines along the road. And they are sufficiently strong there, I think, that it is going to be very, very difficult for the Persians to make a full frontal attack. So there is now a kind of stalemate. And this is promising for,
不，并不是真的，因为他们的力量和权力来自步兵。所以即使是那些非常富有的人通常也会步行作战。这决定了他们的策略。基本上，他们必须保持防御阵地。他们负担不起进入平原的代价，否则那真的会是末日。但实际上，他们不需要离开高地，因为他们及时赶到，封锁了波斯人向雅典的任何推进。在某种程度上，米尔提阿德斯的计划奏效了。在高地上有一座赫拉克勒斯神庙，前面有一片树林，提供了一定程度的掩护。所以他们加固了赫拉克勒斯神庙。他们沿着道路排开阵线。我认为他们在那里足够强大，波斯人要进行全面正面攻击将非常非常困难。所以现在陷入了一种僵局。这对
the Athenians because it means that there might be time now for reinforcements to arrive. The Athenians are not generally very popular. They're a big city. They throw their weight around their indecis going on about how brilliant they are with their liberty and everything. Other cities find them annoying. But they do have one city which is completely committed to the Athenian cause. This city loves Athens.
雅典人来说是有希望的，因为这意味着现在可能有时间等待增援部队到达。雅典人通常不太受欢迎。他们是一个大城市。他们到处炫耀自己的力量，不停地谈论他们那伟大的自由等等。其他城市觉得他们很烦人。但他们确实有一个完全致力于雅典事业的城市。这个城市热爱雅典。
And this is a city called Plataia, a very small city. which lies to the north-west of Athens, in the sphere of influence of Thebes, which has always been the Athenians' traditional enemy, although Hippias, the old Tyrannos had had quite good relations with the Thebans. But when he'd been expelled, the Athenians had gone back to their old ways and kind of gone to war with the Thebans. And as a democracy, Athens had become Plateria's big brother because Plater is always being kind of menaced by the Thebans. And so the Athenians step in and say, well, yeah, we'll protect you. We'll look after you. And now it's the Athenians hour of need. And so the Plotians remember the debt. And even though they're a very small city, they can only
这就是普拉提亚，一个非常小的城市。它位于雅典西北部，处于底比斯的势力范围内，底比斯一直是雅典传统的敌人，尽管老僭主希庇亚斯与底比斯人关系不错。但当他被驱逐后，雅典人恢复了旧习，与底比斯人开战。作为民主国家，雅典成了普拉提亚的大哥，因为普拉提亚总是受到底比斯人的威胁。所以雅典人介入说，好吧，我们会保护你。我们会照顾你。现在是雅典人需要帮助的时候了。所以普拉提亚人记住了这份恩情。即使他们是一个非常小的城市，他们也只能
raise about 800 men. They send all those 800 men to bolster the Athenian army. And it's not a huge contingent. But obviously, their arrival touches every Athenian heart. I mean, it's an incredibly moving scene when they arrive. This is the little ships at Dunkirk moment. And the Athenians will never forget. They will never forget this moment. But there are of course two cities that have, two major cities that have stood against the Persians.
召集大约800人。他们派出了所有这800人来加强雅典军队。这不是一支庞大的队伍。但显然，他们的到来触动了每一个雅典人的心。我的意思是，当他们到达时，这是一个令人难以置信的感人场景。这就是敦刻尔克的小船时刻。雅典人永远不会忘记。他们永远不会忘记这一刻。但当然有两个城市，两个主要城市一直站在波斯人的对立面。
So one is Athens and the other is Sparta. And the Athenians must be thinking, are the Spartans going to show up? We need the Spartans to join us. Right. And the Spartans, of course, are the most formidable military power in Greece. so to have the Spartans turn up would really tilt the balance in favour of the Athenians, I think. And because of that, even as the mass of the Athenian army is heading towards marathon from Athens, there is one Athenian who is heading in the opposite direction and taking the road
一个是雅典，另一个是斯巴达。雅典人一定在想，斯巴达人会出现吗？我们需要斯巴达人加入我们。没错。而斯巴达人当然是希腊最强大的军事力量。所以如果斯巴达人出现，我认为这真的会使天平向雅典人倾斜。正因为如此，即使雅典军队的主力正从雅典向马拉松进军，也有一名雅典人正朝着相反的方向前进，走上了
that will lead him to the Isthmus of Corinth and then down through the Peloponnese towards Sparta. And this is a man called Phidipides, and he is celebrated as the greatest runner in the whole of Athens. And he covers the 140 miles that separate Athens from Sparta in two days. So an incredible feat. And on the second evening of this epic run, he arrives in the wallless plains of Sparta. And he brings his news, the Persians have landed at Marathon. And the Athenians have every hope that the Spartans will come. They are a very proud military power. Their prestige is at stake if they don't come to support the Athenians in their hour of need, I think. They have chucked Dares' messengers down a well and told them to get earth and water from
通往科林斯地峡，然后穿过伯罗奔尼撒半岛前往斯巴达的道路。这个人叫菲迪皮德斯，他被誉为雅典最伟大的奔跑者。他在两天内跑完了雅典到斯巴达之间的140英里。这是一项令人难以置信的壮举。在这场史诗般奔跑的第二个傍晚，他抵达了没有城墙的斯巴达平原。他带来了消息：波斯人已经在马拉松登陆。雅典人满怀希望斯巴达人会来。他们是一个非常自豪的军事强国。我认为如果他们不来支持雅典人度过难关，他们的声誉就会受到威胁。他们曾把大流士的使者扔进井里，让他们从
there. You know, this is Sparta and all of that. Yeah. And they've promised that they will come. And, you know, the Spartans don't give their word lightly. And so Fidipides arrives. He's obviously, I'm imagining very much out of breath, but he pants it out. Oh, men of Sparta, the Athenians beg you for assistance.
那里获取泥土和水。你知道，这就是斯巴达等等。是的。他们承诺会来。而且，你知道，斯巴达人不会轻易许诺。所以菲迪皮德斯到了。我能想象他气喘吁吁，但他喘着气说出来。哦，斯巴达人，雅典人恳求你们的援助。
Do not, by looking the other way, allow the most ancient city in Greece. to fall into bondage and the clutches of barbarians. Ah, but the timing is terrible because the Spartans are celebrating a great feast. This is the feast of the Carnaya. It's sacred to Apollo, and it is one of their holiest festivals. And it's a time of truce.
不要因为视而不见，就让希腊最古老的城市陷入奴役和野蛮人的魔爪。啊，但时机太糟糕了，因为斯巴达人正在庆祝一个盛大的节日。这就是卡尔内亚节。它对阿波罗神圣，是他们最神圣的节日之一。这是一个休战期。
The Spartans just cannot fight during the festival of the Carnaya. Well, even if the persons are attacking, they still can't, they've got important, you know, religious duties and they can't. No. And it's often been assumed that this is, you know, that they're scamming it, that they don't really come, that they're happy. I don't think this is true at all. The Spartans are, by our lights, madly superstitious. So we did an episode on the Battle of Thermopylae that takes place 10 years after marathon. And there's all kinds of shenanigans there because the Spartans can't send troops to Thermopylae, because
斯巴达人在卡尔内亚节期间根本不能打仗。嗯，即使波斯人正在进攻，他们仍然不能，他们有重要的，你知道，宗教职责，他们不能。不。人们经常认为这是，你知道，他们在找借口，他们不想来，他们很高兴。我不认为这是真的。按照我们的标准，斯巴达人是疯狂的迷信。所以我们做了一集关于马拉松战役十年后发生的温泉关战役的节目。那里有各种各样的花招，因为斯巴达人不能派兵去温泉关，因为
the festival Olympia, the Olympic Games is on. And I think it's exactly the same. They do, if they're going to go and fight the, the Persians, they don't want to annoy Apollo before they do it. I mean, that's mad. So I think that their, their inability to leave is entirely genuine. Their religious scruples are not just kind of invented. And so they say to Fidipides, we're really sorry.
奥林匹亚节，奥林匹克运动会正在进行。我认为这完全一样。如果他们要出去与波斯人作战，他们不想在行动之前惹恼阿波罗。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。所以我认为他们无法离开是完全真诚的。他们的宗教顾虑不仅仅是编造出来的。所以他们对菲迪皮德斯说，我们真的很抱歉。
We can't leave for another week. And then it will probably take us three or four days to get to marathon. So that's 10 days in all. We're really sorry, but we will be with you in 10 days. So Fadipides is gutted by this, but I guess it's not a complete disaster, at least if the Athenians can hold their position, then the Spartans may arrive. He heads out of Sparta.
我们一周内无法离开。然后我们可能需要三四天才能到达马拉松。所以总共是10天。我们真的很抱歉，但我们会在10天内赶到。所以菲迪皮德斯对此感到非常沮丧，但我猜这并不是彻底的灾难，至少如果雅典人能守住阵地，那么斯巴达人可能会赶到。他离开了斯巴达。
He takes the mountain road that leads up through the highlands of central Peloponnese. And while he's up in the highlands, he meets someone who promises that he will be at marathon with the Athenians, come what may. And this is a very unexpected apparition. It's a figure with the legs of a goat, two curling horns, and an absolutely enormous phallus. And this is the god Pan. And he is a god who's so notorious for for ambushing wayfarers like Fidipides, kind of lonely up in the mountain heights and filling them with terror, that that sense of terror has its own name in Greek, which derives from Pan, and the word is Panicon, from which we get our English word, panic. And so that gives you a sense of what Pan may be offering to bring to the table when and if
他走的是穿过伯罗奔尼撒中部高地的山路。当他在高地上时，他遇到了一个承诺无论如何都会与雅典人一起出现在马拉松的人。这是一个非常意想不到的幻影。这是一个长着山羊腿、两只卷曲的角、生殖器极其巨大的形象。这就是潘神。他是一位以伏击像菲迪皮德斯这样在山间孤独行走的旅人并让他们充满恐惧而闻名的神，那种恐惧感在希腊语中有它自己的名字，源自潘，这个词是“Panicon”，也就是我们英语单词“panic”（恐慌）的来源。所以这让你感觉到当马拉松战役发生时，潘神可能会带来什么，因为他告诉菲迪皮德斯，他有一个口信要带给雅典人。为什么，当我如此喜欢你们时，你们却拒绝我？我过去曾给过你们许多恩惠，将来也会这样做。所以本质上，潘神是在说，如果你们给予我应有的尊重，你知道，你们给我献祭，赞美我，为我举办节日等等，那么我就会在马拉松与你们同在，我会让波斯人充满恐慌。所以如果菲迪皮德斯记下了这一点，他继续赶路，他到达了马拉松，传达了潘神的口信，也传达了斯巴达人的口信。他们会在10天后到达。有好消息也有坏消息。
a battle is fought at marathon, because he tells Fidipides that he has a message for the Athenians. Why, when I am so fond of you, do you rebuff me? I have done you many favours in the past and will do so again in the future. So essentially, Pan is saying, if you offer me the respect that I am due, you know, you give me sacrifices, celebrate me, give me festivals and things, then I will be at marathon with you and I will fill the Persians with a sense of panic. And so if I diputees banks this, he carries on on his way, he gets the marathon and he passes on the message from Pan and he passes on the message from the Spartans. They're going to be there in 10 days time. There's good news and bad news.
斯巴达人会晚一点。另一方面，我认为斯巴达人的消息，我的意思是，这有点令人沮丧，但并不是彻底的打击，因为他们有能力守住阵地并等待。这对波斯人来说是个问题。波斯人有一套非常精通的间谍系统。所以几乎可以肯定，在菲迪皮德斯到达雅典营地后不久，他们就会知道斯巴达人可能到达的日期。
The Spartans are going to be a bit today. On the other hand, I think that the news of the Spartans, I mean, it's a bit of a downer, but it's not a complete downer because they can afford to hold their positions and wait. It is a problem for the Persians. The Persians have a very proficient espionage system. So it's almost certain that they would know the likely date of the Spartan arrival pretty soon after the arrival of Fidipides in the Athenian camp.
他们的处境很棘手。因为一方面，他们真的负担不起攻击雅典人的防御阵地。这要求太高了。另一方面，你知道，他们需要在斯巴达人到达之前把一切都搞定。所以他们有这10天的窗口期。没错。那么他们会怎么做呢？现在，米尔提阿德斯非常熟悉
And their situation is a tricky one. Because on the one hand, they can't really afford to attack the Athenian's defensive position. It's too big an ask. On the other hand, you know, they need to get everything done and dusted before the Spartans arrive. So they have this kind of 10-day window. Right. So what are they going to do? Now, Miltaiades is very familiar.
他们的作战方式。我认为他有一个非常精明的想法，波斯人最终会做什么。而且这很可能，你知道，从一开始就是他所预料他们会做的事情。但只有时间能证明他是否正确。所以我不会说波斯人做了什么，
with their way of making war. And I think he has a very shrewd idea what the Persians will end up doing. And it's probably, you know, right from the beginning, what he's been expecting they are going to do. But only time will tell if he is right. So I'm not going to say what the Persians do,
但我们将看到米尔提阿德斯是否正确。所以一天过去了，又一天，再一天。时间到了，距离斯巴达人预计到达还有四天，这种僵局将波斯人困在平原上，雅典人封锁了他们离开平原的出口，就在这条关键的道路上。在斯巴达人预计到达的前四天，太阳落在了俯瞰马拉松的山脉后面，月亮在天空中升起，银光闪闪。在遥远的斯巴达，卡尔内亚节现在结束了。斯巴达人正在集结，他们准备出发。与此同时，在波斯营地，当黄昏被黑夜的黑暗所取代时，雅典人听到了这种不可思议的骚动，那是成千上万双沉重的脚步声，正穿过平原向雅典阵地移动。所以雅典人想知道发生了什么。这是全面正面突击，还是佯攻，或者发生了什么？而那个问题的答案
but we will see whether Milchides is right or not. So a day passes and then another and then another. And in time, there are four days left until the Spartans are due to arrive and this deadlock holds the persians down in the plain the Athenians blocking their exit from the plane on this crucial road and four days before the Spartans are due to arrive the sun sets behind the mountains that look on marathon and the moon rises silver in the sky and in distant Sparta the Karnia is now over the Spartans are mustering they are getting ready to march. And meanwhile, in the Persian camp, as dusk is succeeded by the darkness of night, the Athenians hear this incredible commotion, and it's the sound of thousands of pairs of tramping feet, moving towards the Athenian positions across the plain. And so the Athenians wonder what's going on. Is this a full frontal assault, or is it a diversion or what's happening? And the answer to
很快就到了。这要归功于随波斯远征队而来的爱奥尼亚应征入伍者，他们几乎可以肯定是米尔提阿德斯招募的，他与爱奥尼亚人有各种联系，可以作为雅典人的间谍。他们带来了如此重大的消息，以至于立即被带到了雅典最高指挥部。那就是卡利马科斯，他是战争执政官，拥有最高指挥权的人；米尔提阿德斯，比雅典任何人都更了解波斯作战方式的人；以及他在将军委员会中的其他九位将军。这就是爱奥尼亚人带来的消息。雅典人听到的脚步声是一支牵制部队的。看来，这并不是突击。它是为了分散他们的注意力。而分散他们对什么的注意力呢？
that question arrives very soon. And this is courtesy of Ionian conscripts who were with the Persian expedition and who've been recruited almost certainly by Miltaiades, who would have had all kinds of contacts with the Ionians to serve the Athenians as spies. And they bring news so momentous that it is immediately brought to the Athenian high command. So that is Klimachus, who is the war Arcon, the guy in overall command, Miltaiades, the man who knows more about the Persian way of war than anyone else in Athens, and his fellow nine generals on the board of generals. And here is the news that the Ionians have brought. The tramping that the Athenians can hear is that of a holding force. It is not, it seems, an assault. It has been sent to distract them. And to distract them from what
嗯，波斯特遣部队正在一分为二的事实。为什么波斯特遣部队一分为二了？因为很明显，达提斯决定，随着斯巴达人的到来迫在眉睫，他需要尽可能地将雅典人困在钳形攻势中。这意味着他想派遣一部分兵力乘坐运输船绕到后面，沿着雅典海岸航行，看看能否找到一个替代的登陆点，然后沿着道路向雅典人进军，并以这种钳形部队抓住他们。他派出了哪部分兵力来做这件事？
Well, the fact that the Persian task force is being divided in two. And why has the Persian task force been divided in two? Because clearly, Datus has decided that with the Spartan arrival now imminent, he needs to trap the Athenians if he possibly can in a pincer movement. And so that means that he wants to send a portion of his forces around the back in transport ships, down the Athenian coast to see if they can find an alternative landing spot, and then to march up the road towards the Athenians and kind of catch them in this pince of force. And which part of his force is he senting to do this?
这是关键的细节。它是由爱奥尼亚间谍提供给雅典最高指挥部的。是骑兵。所以爱奥尼亚人传达的这个著名短语：骑兵已经离开了。他们正在离开平原。在这里，如果雅典人敢于抓住它，就是他们巨大的、巨大的机会。这是在波斯特遣部队中最致命的部分——他们的骑兵——缺席战场的情况下，与波斯人交战的机会。
And this is the crucial detail. And it is given to the Athenian high command by the Ionian spies. It's the horsemen. So this famous phrase that the Ionians deliver, the cavalry have left. They're leaving the plane. And here, if the Athenians can only dare to seize it, is their big, big opportunity. It is the chance to take on the Persians, while the most lethal part of their task force, their cavalry, are absent from the field of battle.
这就是关键细节。爱奥尼亚间谍将此情报传达给了雅典最高指挥部。是骑兵。所以爱奥尼亚人传达的那句名言是：骑兵已经离开了。他们正在撤离平原。此时，如果雅典人敢于抓住机会，这就是他们千载难逢的良机。这是与波斯人交战的机会，而此时波斯军队中最致命的部分——骑兵——正不在战场上。
But of course, to do that will require the Athenians to leave their defensive positions and advance down into the plane. And so the huge question is, will the Athenians dare to seize this opportunity? What an unbelievable cliffhanger. Will the Athenians seize the moment? Find out after the break. On a rainy bridge over an Amsterdam canal, bearded Dutchmen in black capes and white ruffs, shake hands on deals that will change the world.
当然，要做到这一点，雅典人就必须离开防御阵地，推进到平原上。所以，一个巨大的问题是，雅典人敢不敢抓住这个机会？真是令人难以置信的悬念。雅典人会抓住这个时机吗？休息之后，为您揭晓。在阿姆斯特丹运河上一座阴雨绵绵的桥上，留着胡须、身穿黑色斗篷、戴着白色拉夫领的荷兰人，正在握手达成将改变世界的交易。
This is the early 1600s. These men have created a company that in today's money is so wealthy that as its peak, it's more than twice the value of Apple and Envidia combined. Hello, Restless History listeners. I'm William Durempal. And I'm Anita Arndan, and we are the hosts of a fellow Gollhanger History podcast called Empire. On Empire this week, we are exploring the extraordinary story of the Dutch East India Company. It's a story of the very first corporate espionage. the colonisation of Indonesia and a swap that leads to the creation of New York City.
这是17世纪初。这些人创建了一家公司，按今天的货币计算，其财富之巨，在巅峰时期是苹果和英伟达总市值的两倍多。你好，《Restless History》的听众们。我是威廉·杜伦帕尔。我是安妮塔·阿丹，我们是Gollhanger旗下历史播客《帝国》的主持人。本周在《帝国》节目中，我们将探索荷兰东印度公司的非凡故事。这是一个关于最早的企业间谍活动、印度尼西亚的殖民化，以及导致纽约市建立的一场交换的故事。
How did a company become so powerful that it could kill and torture in the name of the spice trade? And how did the rivalry between the British and the Dutch end with the British East India Company with the most lucrative colony on earth and the Dutch East India Company completely bankrupt? You can access our miniseries today by searching Empire World History wherever you get your podcasts. And we've included a clip from the miniseries at the end of this episode for you to enjoy. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers The Rest is Science.
一家公司是如何变得如此强大，以至于可以以香料贸易的名义进行杀戮和折磨的？英国和荷兰之间的竞争又是如何以英国东印度公司拥有地球上最赚钱的殖民地，而荷兰东印度公司彻底破产而告终的？您可以通过在任何收听播客的地方搜索“Empire World History”来访问我们的迷你剧。我们在本集结尾处为您附上了一段迷你剧的片段，供您欣赏。嘿，这是来自Gollhangers《The Rest is Science》的迈克尔和汉娜。
This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. We often think of beating cancer as treatment, but imagine stopping it before it begins. After years of work, Cancer Research UK scientists are launching a clinical trial of lung vax, the first vaccine designed to prevent lung cancer. It builds on TracerX, the world's largest cancer evolution study, which tracked lung cancer cells over many years to uncover the disease's earliest warning signs. Lung Vax is designed to train the immune system to spot these signs early on, destroying faulty cells before cancer develops. So it's not treatment, but preventative, with the potential to stop lung cancer before it starts. The first stage of the trial starts this year focusing on people at higher risk.
本集由英国癌症研究中心赞助。我们通常认为战胜癌症就是治疗，但想象一下在癌症发生之前就阻止它。经过多年的努力，英国癌症研究中心的科学家们正在启动“肺疫苗”（Lung Vax）的临床试验，这是首个旨在预防肺癌的疫苗。它建立在“TracerX”的基础上，这是全球最大的癌症演化研究项目，通过多年追踪肺癌细胞，揭示了该疾病最早的预警信号。肺疫苗旨在训练免疫系统及早发现这些信号，在癌症发展之前摧毁异常细胞。所以这不是治疗，而是预防，有潜力在肺癌发生前将其阻断。试验的第一阶段将于今年开始，重点针对高风险人群。
It shows what long-term research makes possible. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit cancerresearchukuk.org forward slash the rest is science. Welcome back to The Rest's history. Dawn has not yet broken on one of the most fateful days, not merely. in Greek history, but perhaps in the history of the world. And we find ourselves in the tent of the war archon, Kalimachus, where he and his captains are debating what to do. So Tom, tell us about who's on which side in this debate?
这展示了长期研究带来的可能性。欲了解更多关于英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究突破以及如何支持他们的信息，请访问 cancerresearchuk.org/the-rest-is-science。欢迎回到《The Rest is History》。在这一天最关键的时刻，黎明尚未破晓，这不仅是希腊历史上的关键时刻，或许也是世界历史上的关键时刻。我们发现自己身处战争执政官卡利马科斯的帐篷里，他和他的指挥官们正在辩论该怎么做。那么汤姆，告诉我们这场辩论中各方都是谁？
Okay, on one side is Miltaiades. And he has one particular advantage in making his case, which is that it is his turn to command the Athenians on this day of days. So that's an incredible slice of luck for him. He is pushing for the Athenians to advance from their defensive positions down into the plane and attack the Asiatic hordes, which are swarming down there. Because he can see with the clarity of the seasoned enemy of the Persians that he is, that there is this precious but fleeting opportunity. And in fact, I think that this is what he had been expecting and waiting for.
好的，一方是米尔提阿德斯。他在陈述自己的观点时有一个独特的优势，那就是在这一关键的日子里，轮到他指挥雅典人了。所以对他来说，这真是天大的运气。他正在推动雅典人从防御阵地推进到平原，攻击那些正在那里蜂拥而至的亚洲大军。因为他以自己作为波斯宿敌的敏锐眼光，看到了这个宝贵但转瞬即逝的机会。事实上，我认为这正是他一直期待和等待的。
This is what he had been expecting the Persians would be forced to do, and he's recognized it as the one chance the Athenians have for victory. So his understanding of what Daitis is up to, I think, is as follows. Datis does not want to wait for the Spartans to arrive, but he can't force the road that leads to Athens. And so his only real option then is to split his forces by loading some of them into transport ships and sending them down the coastline. And if he's going to do that, then it makes sense to send his cavalry, because they can then
这正是他预料到波斯人会被迫采取的行动，他将其视为雅典人获胜的唯一机会。所以我认为他对达提斯意图的理解如下：达提斯不想等待斯巴达人到来，但他无法强行通过通往雅典的道路。因此，他唯一真正的选择就是分兵，将部分军队装上运输船，沿着海岸线南下。如果他要这样做，那么派骑兵随行是有道理的，因为他们可以
advance back up the road as fast as possible. And if the intelligence that has been brought to the Athenians by their spies in the Persian camp is accurate, then this is exactly what is happening. This person holding force has been sent to distract the Athenians while far in the rear, the cavalry are being clandestinely loaded onto the transport ships and starting to sail away down the Attic coast. So the Athenians will never have a better chance of victory. The invaders army is divided and the cavalry have temporarily vacated the field. But this window of opportunity is going to close very fast. They have to seize their opportunity as soon as they possibly can. And four of Miltadis fellow generals are convinced by this, but five are appalled by it. And I think
尽快沿路推进回来。如果雅典人从波斯军营的间谍那里得到的情报是准确的，那么这正是正在发生的事情。这支牵制部队被派去分散雅典人的注意力，而远在后方，骑兵正被秘密装上运输船，开始沿着阿提卡海岸航行离开。所以雅典人永远不会有比这更好的获胜机会了。入侵者的军队被分割，骑兵暂时离开了战场。但这个机会之窗很快就会关闭。他们必须尽可能快地抓住这个机会。米尔提阿德斯的四位将军同僚被说服了，但有五位对此感到震惊。我认为
it's important to emphasize just how terrifying the suggestion that Miltadis is making, that they are being asked to attack the Persians on open ground, which the Athenians have always known is the one place you don't attack the Persians, without archers, without cavalry, still outnumbered, even if the cavalry has gone. And just to reiterate, no Greek army has ever defeated the Persians in open combat. So you can see why there is opposition to Miltides' plan. I mean, so much hangs in the balance. And they're evenly divided, aren't they? So the casting vote will go to the war. Arcon, Calimachus, and which way will he side? He sides with Miltaiades.
强调米尔提阿德斯提出的建议有多么可怕是很重要的，他们被要求在开阔地带攻击波斯人，而雅典人一直都知道那是绝对不能攻击波斯人的地方，没有弓箭手，没有骑兵，即使骑兵已经离开，他们的人数仍然处于劣势。再次重申，没有任何希腊军队曾在公开战斗中击败过波斯人。所以你可以理解为什么米尔提阿德斯的计划会遭到反对。我的意思是，胜负悬于一线。他们势均力敌，不是吗？所以决定性的一票将投给战争执政官卡利马科斯，他会站在哪一边？他站在了米尔提阿德斯这边。
Let's go for it. Yeah, the order is given. Battle is going to be joined at dawn. Messengers go throughout the camp. The Athenians start to wake up, and they are told the news that they are going to descend into the plane, and there will be a battle for the future of Athens fought that day. So they get up, they have their breakfast, and then slaves bring them. Their equipment, Hoplar, so their shields, their helmets, their spears.
干吧。是的，命令下达了。战斗将在黎明时分打响。信使传遍了整个营地。雅典人开始醒来，他们被告知消息：他们将下到平原，那天将为雅典的未来而战。于是他们起床，吃过早餐，然后奴隶们带来了他们的装备，重装步兵的装备，也就是他们的盾牌、头盔、长矛。
And Hopla is the word that gives us the name for a Greek heavy infantryman, hoplite. And the bare minimum that these hoplites would have is a helmet, a shield, a spear, a sword. And some of the Pleitians don't even have helmets. They just have leather caps, which are called dog skins. So not everybody is kind of sheathed in bronze. But most Athenians, they do have corselets. Some of these corselets are of bronze. Some are made of layers of cloth stuck onto a kind of leather jerkin.
“Hopla”这个词就是希腊重装步兵“hoplite”名称的来源。这些重装步兵最基本的装备是头盔、盾牌、长矛和剑。有些普拉提亚人甚至没有头盔。他们只有被称为“狗皮”的皮帽。所以并不是每个人都全身披挂青铜。但大多数雅典人确实有胸甲。有些胸甲是青铜制的。有些是由粘在皮革背心上的多层布料制成的。
Some of these leather jerkins would have bronze scale sewn into them. And also you would put bronze grieves on your shins to protect your legs. And so there's no uniformity in terms of kit. And the total weight is kind of estimated between 30, 70 pounds. I mean, that's quite a lot. lot. And the most heavily armoured of all, those who can afford the most armor, I mean, they are kind of fearsome automata of bronze. I mean, they are really, really very heavily clad. And by dawn, so as the sun is rising to the east over the Aegean, the hoplites are ready for
有些皮革背心上缝有青铜鳞片。你还会穿上青铜护胫来保护你的腿。所以装备并不统一。总重量估计在30到70磅之间。我的意思是，那相当重。而装备最精良、买得起最多盔甲的人，他们简直就是可怕的青铜自动机。我的意思是，他们穿得真的非常厚重。到了黎明，当太阳从爱琴海东边升起时，重装步兵们已经准备好
battle. If they've got breastplates, they've put them on, if they've got greaves, they've strapped them on, they've got their shields, they've got their spears in their hands, they've got their helmets propped up on the back of their heads. And then, of course, they have to be a raid for battle. And the customary Athenian practice is to line up a phalanx, the great kind of porcupine of spears that is formed by lines and lines of Greek infantrymen equipped with spears. Normally, an Athenian phalanx consists of eight lines. But Miltaiades, he can see down into the plain now. There's a kind of grey light as the sun. starts to rise. And he can see that the Persian lines, because they outnumber the Athenians so
战斗了。如果他们有胸甲，他们就穿上；如果有护胫，他们就绑上；他们拿好盾牌，握住长矛，把头盔推到脑后。然后，当然，他们必须列阵战斗。雅典人的惯例是排成方阵，这是一种由一排排装备长矛的希腊步兵组成的巨大“豪猪”。通常，雅典方阵由八排组成。但米尔提阿德斯现在可以俯瞰平原。当太阳开始升起时，有一种灰蒙蒙的光。他可以看到波斯人的阵线，因为他们的人数比雅典人多得多，
strongly, is much longer than if the Athenian phalanx was eight lines deep. And so he extends the Athenian line to match the Persian line. And he does this by thinning out the centre. So the centre is given to three of the generals, one of whom is a young general called Themistocles, who will have an important role to play in subsequent Athenian history. And he is stationed in the weak and center. Kalimachus, the War Archon. He commands the right wing. That's the traditional place that the War Archon stands.
所以比雅典方阵八排深度的阵线要长得多。于是他拉长了雅典的阵线以匹配波斯阵线。他通过削弱中心来做到这一点。所以中心交给了三位将军，其中一位是年轻的将军地米斯托克利，他在随后的雅典历史中将扮演重要角色。他驻扎在薄弱的中心。战争执政官卡利马科斯指挥右翼。那是战争执政官站立的传统位置。
And the Pateans in their leather helmets are stationed on the left. So they are lined up. Sacrifice is offered. The portents are good. Miltaiades then stands where everyone can hear him. And he gives the command at them. And there's a great shimmering of metal. as the hoplites lower their helmets, they heft their shields and they shoulder their spears.
而戴着皮头盔的普拉提亚人驻扎在左翼。于是他们列好了阵。祭祀已经完成。预兆很好。米尔提阿德斯站在每个人都能听到的地方。他下达了命令：冲锋。金属发出巨大的闪光，重装步兵们拉下头盔，举起盾牌，扛起长矛。
And you can imagine how terrifying this moment must be. You know, you are a hoplight. Your head is now encased in metal. You are effectively cut off from all the sounds around you. The trumpets are braying to signal the start of the advance, but you can barely hear it through the bronze of your helmet. But what you do have is the kind of this great collective jolting of the Athenian line as your fellows onto your left and to your right start the descent. And so you have no choice. Even if you're absolutely coward, you still have to advance.
你可以想象那一刻有多么可怕。你知道，你是一名重装步兵。你的头现在被金属包裹。你实际上与周围所有的声音隔绝了。号角声吹响，示意冲锋开始，但你几乎无法透过青铜头盔听到它。但你确实感受到雅典阵线那种巨大的集体震动，因为你左边和右边的同伴开始了冲锋。所以你别无选择。即使你是个彻头彻尾的懦夫，你也必须前进。
I think everyone on that morning must have felt terror. But I think that people in that advance are kind of borne on the intoxication as well as the dread of the moment. moment. And, you know, we know that when Greeks advance into battle, there are those who wet themselves. There are those who void their bowels and streak their cloaks. But you advance because you feel yourself to be part of a collective. You are kind of one with your fellow citizens. And I think that Herodotus in, you know, we read it in the previous episode, that sense that being part of a democracy probably does give a sense of fellowship to an Athenian phalanx that perhaps hadn't previously existed. So as you descend down that slope onto the plane of marathon, I think you probably do feel
我想那天早上的每个人一定都感到了恐惧。但我认为在那次冲锋中的人们，既被那一刻的狂喜所鼓舞，也被恐惧所笼罩。你知道，我们知道当希腊人冲入战场时，有人会尿裤子。有人会排泄并弄脏斗篷。但你前进是因为你感到自己是集体的一部分。你与你的公民同伴融为一体。我认为希罗多德在上一集中提到的那种感觉，即作为民主制的一部分，可能确实给雅典方阵带来了一种以前可能不存在的友谊感。所以当你沿着斜坡冲向马拉松平原时，我想你可能确实感到
that you are part of a body of freeborn men. I think that it would not be wrong to say that that is part of what steals the Athenians to take this incredible risk of marching down to meet an enemy who has never been defeated by a Greek army before. And they have a mile to cover. And incredible stories in due course come to be told of this advance. It's said that the Athenians ran the whole way down towards the Persian lines. I mean, this is impossible. The weight of their kit is so heavy that they couldn't possibly have managed that and then fought a battle.
你是自由人集体的一部分。我认为说这是雅典人敢于冒着巨大的风险，冲下去迎战一支从未被希腊军队击败过的敌人的部分原因，并不为过。他们有一英里的路程要跑。关于这次冲锋，后来流传着不可思议的故事。据说雅典人一路跑向波斯阵线。我的意思是，这不可能。他们的装备太重了，他们不可能做到这一点还能进行战斗。
But I think it's clear that as they near the enemy, they do start to run. And Herodotus is very, very precise about this. they were, he writes, so far as we can tell, the very first Greeks anywhere to make use of running towards an enemy as a tactic, and the first not to cringe before the sight of Median dress, so Persian dress, and the men who wear it, hitherto Greeks had only had to hear the name of the Medes to be reduced to a state of terror. And they reach the Persian lines and they crash into the Persian lines and the impact is absolutely devastating. It's this great pulverizing, smash up of metal into flesh and bone. And the Persian forces are much more lightly armored than the Greeks. You know, they have probably quilted jerkins at best. And this means that when the Athenians smash into them and they're using their spears, the spears don't shiver as they would if they were crashing into another phalanx. And that means that the Persians can be skewered and those who aren't skewered can be trampled underfoot by the sheer weight of all these bronze clans.
但我认为很明显，当他们接近敌人时，他们确实开始奔跑。希罗多德对此非常非常精确。他写道，据我们所知，他们是第一批在任何地方使用向敌人奔跑作为战术的希腊人，也是第一批在看到米底服饰（即波斯服饰）和穿这种衣服的人面前不退缩的人，此前希腊人只要听到米底人的名字就会陷入恐惧。他们到达了波斯阵线，猛烈地撞击波斯阵线，冲击力绝对是毁灭性的。这是一种巨大的、将金属粉碎进血肉和骨头里的撞击。波斯军队的装备比希腊人轻得多。你知道，他们充其量只有绗缝背心。这意味着当雅典人撞击他们并使用长矛时，长矛不会像撞击另一个方阵那样折断。这意味着波斯人可以被串起来，而那些没被串起来的人会被所有这些青铜包裹的士兵的重量踩在脚下。
men. And then of course, Dominant, you, I think with your expression, you conveyed a certain sense of skepticism as to whether Pan with his curling goat horns and his enormous phallus was going to turn up. That was a little skeptical. Yeah. Well, he does turn up because the Persians are afflicted with a terrible sense of panic. Right. And on the wings, they turn and they flee and they start scurpering for the boats which are drawn up at the far end of the plane on the beach. And only in the centre does the Persian force have the better of the fight because that's where the Athenian line has been weakened and also it's where the best Persian troops are. So the Persians themselves and also the Saka, the Skittians, who have these kind of enormous cleaving axes like
然后当然，多米尼克，我想你的表情传达了一种怀疑，怀疑长着卷曲山羊角和巨大阴茎的潘神是否会出现。那有点怀疑。是的。好吧，他确实出现了，因为波斯人陷入了一种可怕的恐慌。没错。在侧翼，他们转身逃跑，开始向停在平原尽头海滩上的船只逃窜。只有在中心，波斯军队在战斗中占据了上风，因为那是雅典阵线被削弱的地方，也是波斯精锐部队所在的地方。所以波斯人自己，还有萨卡人、斯基泰人，他们有那种巨大的劈砍斧，就像
the housecars at the Battle of Hastings. And it looks briefly as though they might break through there. But the Athenian wings who have sent the Persian wings fleeing, they are able to kind of curl around and to catch the Persians and the Saka on their flanks. And the Persian Centre then starts retreating and then panicking as well. And they're all streaming across the plane, running for the ships to try and get away. So by this point, the battle is won. But it isn't yet over because, of course, the fighting now moves to the ships, because the Athenians are as desperate to stop the Persians from getting away as the Persians are to make their escape. And the Persians have the advantage, of course, that on their wings, the men who have broken there have a head start,
黑斯廷斯战役中的皇家卫队一样。看起来他们似乎可能会在那里突破。但已经让波斯侧翼溃逃的雅典侧翼，能够绕过来，从侧翼包抄波斯人和萨卡人。波斯中心随后开始撤退，然后也陷入了恐慌。他们全都涌过平原，奔向船只试图逃跑。所以到这一点，战斗已经赢了。但还没有结束，因为当然，战斗现在转移到了船上，因为雅典人阻止波斯人逃跑的决心，和波斯人逃跑的决心一样强烈。当然，波斯人有优势，因为在他们的侧翼，那些已经突破的人有先发优势，
and so they are able to start piling into the ships before the Athenians arrive. But once the Athenians get to the beach where all the Persian ships are drawn up, there is very, very desperate fighting. And this, I'm sorry to say, is where the war Arcon dies. So Callimachus. You're right, because Athenians don't have this all their own way, do they? I mean, we don't want to give the impression that it's basically the Athenians completely wiping the floor with the Persians and the Persians doing nothing in response. I mean, they're fighting pretty ferociously too. Yeah, so it's on the beaches that the Athenian casualties are heaviest. So we say Calimachus dies there, the War Archon, another of the ten generals, he dies there. And there's a very famous story. The one Athenian reaches up to
所以他们能够在雅典人到达之前开始挤上船。但一旦雅典人到达停泊着所有波斯船只的海滩，战斗就变得非常非常绝望。我很遗憾地说，战争执政官就是在这里阵亡的。也就是卡利马科斯。你是对的，因为雅典人并没有完全掌控局面，不是吗？我的意思是，我们不想给人留下这样的印象：雅典人完全碾压了波斯人，而波斯人没有做出任何回应。我的意思是，他们也打得非常凶猛。是的，所以正是在海滩上，雅典人的伤亡最惨重。所以我们说卡利马科斯死在那里，十位将军中的另一位也死在那里。有一个非常著名的故事。一位雅典人伸手去抓
the prow of a ship that is pulling away to try and stop it. And there's a person with an axe who swings it down, chops off the Athenian's hand who collapses into the sea, blood spraying everywhere. And this Athenian is the brother of Iskullus, who is the first of the three great Athenian tragedians of the 5th century BC. And Iskoulos himself is also fighting at Marathon. And he has this famous epitaph so when he dies, he doesn't mention any of his tragedies. He just said, you know, I was at Marathon. I fought against the long-haired mead. That was the one thing that he was proud of.
一艘正在驶离的船的船头，试图阻止它。有一个波斯人挥舞着斧头砍了下来，砍掉了雅典人的手，他倒在海里，鲜血四溅。这位雅典人是埃斯库罗斯的兄弟，埃斯库罗斯是公元前5世纪三位伟大的雅典悲剧作家中的第一位。埃斯库罗斯本人也参加了马拉松战役。他有这句著名的墓志铭，所以当他去世时，他没有提到他的任何悲剧。他只是说，你知道，我在马拉松。我与长发的米底人作战。那是他唯一引以为豪的事情。
So the Athenians do manage to capture some of the Persians to kind of burn them. But the mass of the fleet does manage to pull away. And so this is a problem for the Athenians because the question now is, well, where is it going to be heading? You know, Athens effectively stands defenseless. And there's an even more alarming question. What about all that cavalry that had embarked and sailed off? And then, even as they're kind of, you know, worrying about these questions, something very, very alarming happens, which is that up on the heights of Mount Pentelicon, the mountain that stands.
所以雅典人确实设法俘虏了一些波斯人，把他们烧死。但大部分舰队确实设法逃脱了。所以这对雅典人来说是个问题，因为现在的问题是，他们要去哪里？你知道，雅典实际上处于无防备状态。还有一个更令人担忧的问题。那些已经登船并航行离开的骑兵呢？然后，就在他们担心这些问题的时候，发生了一件非常非常令人担忧的事情，那就是在彭特利孔山的顶峰，那座矗立在
between marathon and Athens. There's a flashing from a mirror or a shield and it's clearly a prearranged signal that is being delivered from someone in Athens, a traitor in Athens, signaling out to the Persian admirals and nobody knows who it is. Nobody will ever know who it is. But it is evident that there is potential treachery afoot. And so the Athenian general say, well, we cannot pause here. We can't rest on our laurels. We've got to get moving. And it's by now 10 o'clock in the morning. The Athenians are obviously exhausted. They're sweat soaked. They're wounded, covered in blood. But all of them are thinking about their families and homes back in Athens. And so they decide we are going to have to march as fast as we can from marathon and get back to Athens. And there is,
马拉松和雅典之间的山。有一道来自镜子或盾牌的闪光，这显然是一个预先安排好的信号，由雅典的某个人，一个雅典的叛徒，发给波斯海军上将的，没人知道那是谁。永远没人会知道那是谁。但很明显，潜在的背叛正在酝酿之中。所以雅典将军们说，好吧，我们不能在这里停下来。我们不能躺在功劳簿上。我们必须行动起来。现在已经是上午10点了。雅典人显然精疲力竭。他们浑身是汗。他们受了伤，浑身是血。但他们所有人都想着雅典的家人和家园。所以他们决定，我们必须以最快的速度从马拉松行军，赶回雅典。当然，
of course, a famous story that I'm sure most people will have heard, that they send Fidipides, the runner ahead of them, to run the 26 miles back to Athens, and he gets there in record time, and he proclaims, rejoice, we have won, and then he dies with the exhaustion and intoxication of the moment. Is this story true? It's not in Herodotus. It's in much later Greek sources, but of course this is what inspires the famous marathon race in the 1896 Olympics. So it might not be true. Might not be true. I mean, I like to think it is.
有一个著名的故事，我相信大多数人都听说过，他们派跑步者菲迪皮德斯跑在他们前面，跑完26英里回到雅典，他以创纪录的时间到达那里，他宣布：“欢呼吧，我们赢了”，然后他因那一刻的精疲力竭和狂喜而死。这个故事是真的吗？希罗多德没有记载。它出现在后来的希腊文献中，但当然，这正是1896年奥运会著名的马拉松比赛的灵感来源。所以它可能不是真的。可能不是真的。我的意思是，我愿意相信它是真的。
All these stories, I prefer to think that they are. And it means that the Battle of Marathon is the only battle to have an Olympic event. But what we know for sure from Herodotus, whether Fidipides has gone ahead of them or not, is that the Athenian army, I mean, to quote Herodotus, they raced back to the defense of their city as fast as their legs could carry them. And astonishingly, they arrive there by late afternoon, and it's just in the nick of time, because not long after they have turned up in Athens, the Persian fleet glides up towards Phelarum, which is the harbour that serves Athens. And so the Athenians march down to
所有这些故事，我更愿意相信它们是真的。这意味着马拉松战役是唯一拥有奥运项目的战役。但我们从希罗多德那里确定的是，无论菲迪皮德斯是否跑在他们前面，雅典军队，引用希罗多德的话，他们以最快的速度赶回保卫他们的城市。令人惊讶的是，他们在傍晚时分到达了那里，而且恰逢其时，因为在他们出现在雅典后不久，波斯舰队就滑向了雅典的港口法勒鲁姆。于是雅典人行军到
Valerium, they draw themselves up in kind of great bronze lines. And the Persian fleet lies stationary off the entrance to the harbour at Phelarum, and then the sun sets its dusk. The Persian fleet raises anchor, swings around and sails eastwards into the night, and the threat of invasion is over, and Athens is saved. But the question I suppose is how long is it saved for? Now, we haven't yet talked about the Spartans. So the Spartans arrive shortly after the battle, don't they? And they've been on the road for three days, so they must be pretty exhausted themselves. Yeah. So that's an impressive march from them. They're late, but they've still, you know, You know, they've done well to get there.
法勒鲁姆，他们排成巨大的青铜阵线。波斯舰队停泊在法勒鲁姆港口入口外，然后太阳落山了，天黑了。波斯舰队起锚，掉头向东驶入黑夜，入侵的威胁结束了，雅典得救了。但我认为问题是，它能维持多久？现在，我们还没有谈到斯巴达人。所以斯巴达人在战斗后不久就到了，不是吗？他们已经在路上走了三天，所以他们自己一定也精疲力竭了。是的。所以这对他们来说是一次令人印象深刻的行军。他们迟到了，但他们仍然，你知道，他们能赶到那里已经很不错了。
Yeah. So great scenes. They congratulate the Athenians. They go to the battlefield and they see there the 6,400 bodies of the fallen Persians. And they, it's an interesting scene, is it? Because the Spartans are very, they're fascinated by what the Persians are wearing, what kit they've got, what arms and armor. Because this is their first chance to look at what the most formidable people in the world.
是的。所以场面很壮观。他们祝贺雅典人。他们来到战场，在那里看到了6400具波斯阵亡者的尸体。这是一个有趣的场景，不是吗？因为斯巴达人非常，他们对波斯人穿什么、带什么装备、有什么武器和盔甲非常着迷。因为这是他们第一次有机会看看世界上最强大的民族拥有什么。
have what they've got. Yeah, it's a bit like, you know, we did the episode on the American attempt to rescue the hostages in Iran and the helicopter crashes. And it's, you know, the Iranians inspect the helicopter because it's a way of trying to understand what the Americans can do. And I think the Spartans are exactly the same that they're looking at the, you know, the armor and the arms and so on that the Persians have. And to be honest, they're not very impressed.
他们有什么。是的，这有点像，你知道，我们做过关于美国在伊朗营救人质和直升机坠毁的那一集。而且，你知道，伊朗人检查直升机是因为这是试图了解美国人能做什么的一种方式。我认为斯巴达人也是一样，他们看着波斯人拥有的盔甲和武器等等。老实说，他们印象并不深刻。
They think, well, you know, we could, we could beat these any day. But equally, I think the fact that the Spartans are so concerned to go and make this inspection is a reflection of the fact not just that they've now woken up to just how major a threat the Persians are, but also this kind of nagging anxiety that even if the Persians have been defeated now at Marathon, you know, they probably will be back. So we should try and, you know, get as much information on them as we possibly can. This raises an interesting question, doesn't it? because to the Greeks, the Battle of Marathon is an event that will echo through the centuries.
他们想，好吧，你知道，我们随时都能打败这些人。但同样，我认为斯巴达人如此关心去进行这次检查，反映出他们不仅意识到波斯人是一个多么重大的威胁，而且还有一种挥之不去的焦虑，即使波斯人在马拉松战役中被击败了，你知道，他们很可能会回来。所以我们应该尽量多地获取关于他们的信息。这提出了一个有趣的问题，不是吗？因为对希腊人来说，马拉松战役是一个将在几个世纪中回响的事件。
It's an absolutely seismic historical moment. But presumably to the Persians, you know, it's what, a sideshow? At best. Peripheral border skirmish, I think, is probably how they would have framed it. A border skirmish that didn't go the way that they had hoped, but such things happen when you're a superpower. I think they probably wouldn't even have mentioned Marathon. I mean, the thing is that the Persians don't write history.
这是一个绝对震撼的历史时刻。但对波斯人来说，这大概是什么，一个插曲？充其量是。我认为他们可能会将其描述为边缘的边境冲突。一场没有按他们希望的方向发展的边境冲突，但当你是一个超级大国时，这种事情就会发生。我想他们可能根本不会提到马拉松。我的意思是，问题在于波斯人不写历史。
in the way, say that Herodotus does. So we don't have any Persian accounts of any of the wars against the Greeks at all. But Robert Graves, so as in I Claudius, he wrote a fantastic poem called the Persian version in which he imagines how the Persians would have spun the defeat at Marathon. So just a quote from it, some of the lines, truth-loving Persians do not dwell upon the trivial skirmish fought near Marathon. Despite a strong defense and adverse weather, all arms combined magnificently together.
像希罗多德那样。所以我们根本没有任何关于波斯对希腊战争的波斯记录。但罗伯特·格雷夫斯，就像在《我，克劳狄》中一样，他写了一首精彩的诗叫《波斯版本》，他在诗中想象了波斯人会如何粉饰马拉松战役的失败。引用其中的几行：“热爱真理的波斯人不会纠结于马拉松附近那场微不足道的冲突。尽管有强大的防御和恶劣的天气，所有兵种还是完美地结合在一起。”
You know, superpowers never acknowledge the fact that they've been defeated. Well, is it not? I was thinking about this. It's the equivalent to them probably of a British defeat in Afghanistan or something in the 19th century. You know, sometimes these things happen on the frontier. I think it's even better than that because don't forget they have actually captured Naxos. They have captured Eretria. And they do lead their armada safely back to the Asian mainland.
你知道，超级大国从不承认他们被击败的事实。好吧，不是吗？我一直在想这个问题。这大概相当于英国在19世纪在阿富汗的失败。你知道，有时这些事情发生在边境。我认为这甚至比那更好，因为别忘了他们实际上已经占领了纳克索斯。他们已经占领了埃雷特里亚。而且他们确实安全地将他们的无敌舰队带回了亚洲大陆。
Most of the ships have survived the Athenian attempt to disqual. destroy them. And when they land back on Asian soil, they then lead the Eretrian captives to the great king in Persia, as they'd been ordered to do. And to quote Herodotus on how Darius responds to the site of these Eretrian prisoners. Before they became the king's prisoners of war, the fury felt by Darius towards the Eretriens had been terrible, wronged as he had originally been by their unprovoked aggression. So you see, Herodotus agrees with the Persian perception that basically the retains had been terrorists. But when Dera saw them led into his presence and utterly at his mercy,
大部分船只在雅典人试图摧毁它们的行动中幸存了下来。当他们回到亚洲土地上时，他们按照命令将埃雷特里亚俘虏带到了波斯大王面前。引用希罗多德关于大流士对看到这些埃雷特里亚囚犯的反应：“在他们成为国王的战俘之前，大流士对埃雷特里亚人的愤怒是可怕的，因为他最初受到了他们无端侵略的伤害。”所以你看，希罗多德同意波斯人的看法，即埃雷特里亚人基本上是恐怖分子。但当大流士看到他们被带到他面前并完全任他摆布时，
he inflicted no further miseries on them, but instead settled them in the land of Kisya. So this is a display of mercy, but it's not a pardon, because Kisya is a region of Iran that it's not the most attractive reason, because it's full of oil wells. And Herodotus describes the oil as black and giving off a revolting stench. So it's one of the earliest descriptions in history of, petroleum. And the Eretrians are settled there and there is no return home for them. And even centuries later, tourists would go and visit their descendants and some of them would still be
他没有再对他们施加任何苦难，而是把他们安置在基西亚地区。所以这是一种仁慈的展示，但不是赦免，因为基西亚是伊朗的一个地区，它不是最吸引人的地区，因为它到处都是油井。希罗多德将石油描述为黑色的，并散发出令人作呕的恶臭。所以这是历史上最早关于石油的描述之一。埃雷特里亚人被安置在那里，他们再也没有回到家乡。即使几个世纪后，游客们还会去拜访他们的后代，其中一些人仍然
speaking Greek. So, you know, for a Greek to be parted from his homeland is a terrible thing. And that might, of course, had the Athenians lost the Battle of Marathon, that might have been the fate of the Athenians. Their city burned, their sons castrated, the survivors exiled. And the fact that Athens had been spared that fate, it was a cause of enormous relief to them, obviously, but it is a cause of the most immense pride as well. Only 192 died at Marathon, most of them on the beaches. And the Athenians saw them as heroes of the city, men who had died for freedom. and so for the first and only time in Athenian history, they are buried on the field where they had fallen.
说着希腊语。所以，你知道，对于一个希腊人来说，与家乡分离是一件可怕的事情。当然，如果雅典人在马拉松战役中失败了，那可能就是雅典人的命运。他们的城市被烧毁，他们的儿子被阉割，幸存者被流放。雅典免于这种命运，这显然让他们感到巨大的宽慰，但这也是一种巨大的骄傲。只有192人在马拉松战役中阵亡，大多数是在海滩上。雅典人视他们为城市的英雄，为自由而死的人。所以雅典历史上唯一一次，他们被埋葬在他们阵亡的战场上。
And a great tomb is raised over the ashes of the 192 dead Athenians, and it's adorned with marble slabs listing the fallen. And you can still visit the site of that mound to this day. It's a very moving place to visit. And on the Acropolis, a great new temple is begun, which effectively is designed as a colossal war memorial. But the big legacy is kind of cultural and ideological, isn't it? it, which is that, you know, you said earlier, no Greek army had ever beaten the Persians in open battle. And so for the Athenians in particular, this is a transformative moment in their self-image, presumably in their relationship with the superpower to the east.
一座巨大的坟墓在192名阵亡雅典人的骨灰上拔地而起，上面装饰着列出阵亡者名单的大理石板。直到今天，你仍然可以参观那个土丘的遗址。这是一个非常感人的地方。在卫城上，一座宏伟的新神庙开始建造，它实际上被设计成一座巨大的战争纪念碑。但巨大的遗产是文化和意识形态上的，不是吗？正如你之前所说，没有希腊军队曾在公开战斗中击败过波斯人。所以对于雅典人来说，这是一个自我形象转变的时刻，大概也是他们与东方超级大国关系转变的时刻。
Yeah, because that sense, I think, of a kind of instinctive cringe before the Persians has gone. And although there remains fear of what the Persians might be able to do, That fear is now kind of tinged with a sense of contempt. And it's telling that in the wake of marathon, the Athenians start applying a new word to the Persians that they hadn't previously used. And this is Barbaroi or Barbarians. And literally it means kind of the speakers of gibberish,
是的，因为那种在波斯人面前本能的畏缩感消失了。尽管对波斯人可能做的事情仍然存在恐惧，但这种恐惧现在带有一种蔑视感。马拉松战役后，雅典人开始对波斯人使用一个他们以前没用过的新词，这很有说明意义。这就是“Barbaroi”或“野蛮人”。字面意思是“说胡话的人”，
people who don't speak Greek. And it conveys a sense of these gibberish speakers as kind of numberless alien, jabbering, a reflection of what the Athenians had seen on the heights above marathon when they looked down at the plane and gazed at the Asiatic hordes. And it's not just the Athenians who have had their confidence boosted. I think the whole of Greece has learnt an invaluable lesson, which is that the Persians aren't invincible, that the barbarians can be defeated, that the Colossus has feet of clay. You know, you defeat a superpower and inevitably it's going to convince you that even
不讲希腊语的人。它传达了一种感觉，即这些说胡话的人是无数的、外来的、叽叽喳喳的，这反映了雅典人在马拉松高地上俯瞰平原、凝视亚洲大军时所看到的景象。不仅雅典人的自信心得到了提升。我认为整个希腊都学到了宝贵的一课，那就是波斯人并非不可战胜，野蛮人是可以被击败的，巨人也有泥足。你知道，你击败了一个超级大国，不可避免地会让你相信，即使
if the superpower comes back at you again, you might be able to see them off. And this, of course, is what duly truly happens, because on one level, plainly the Battle of Marathon isn't decisive at all, because 10 years later in 480 BC, the Persians are back. And this time with a vastly greater force and led in person by their king, the son of Darius Xerxes. And this time, the Athenians do not meet the Persians with their infantry. They meet them with a fleet at the Battle of Salis. And they're commanded at Salamis by Themistocles, the young general who had been in command of his tribe at the center of the weakened Athenian battle line at Marathon. And you could say that Salamis, because it's a great victory for Athens and for the Greeks, and it effectively destroys the hopes of the Persians of conquering Greece, that that's more decisive than Marathon. But I think Marathon does deserve to be seen as decisive and for two reasons. I think, that had Athens been defeated, destroyed, burned, the Persians would have been back, and I think the Spartans might have resisted, but I don't think anyone else would have done.
超级大国再次回来找你，你也许能打发他们走。当然，这确实发生了，因为在某种程度上，马拉松战役根本不是决定性的，因为10年后，即公元前480年，波斯人又回来了。这一次，他们带着规模大得多的军队，由他们的国王、大流士的儿子薛西斯亲自率领。这一次，雅典人没有用步兵迎战波斯人。他们在萨拉米斯战役中用舰队迎战他们。他们在萨拉米斯由地米斯托克利指挥，他就是那位在马拉松战役中指挥雅典薄弱中心阵线的年轻将军。你可以说，萨拉米斯因为是雅典和希腊人的伟大胜利，有效地摧毁了波斯人征服希腊的希望，所以它比马拉松更具决定性。但我认为马拉松确实值得被视为决定性的，原因有二。我认为，如果雅典被击败、摧毁、烧毁，波斯人会卷土重来，我想斯巴达人可能会抵抗，但我认为其他人不会。
So I think that the victory at marathon gives not just Athens, but all the cities of Greece that decide to resist the Persian invasion. It gives them the backbone to do that. And I do also think that had Athens been annihilated, as Meletus had been annihilated, as Eretria had been annihilated, then that would have had profound consequences for the future. So its democracy would have been pretty much still born. Its cultural impact would have been immense. No Parthenon, no tragedy, no Thucydides, in fact, probably no Herodotus. Erodotus probably would not have been inspired to write his great history. And also, it would have had an incalculable impact on the development of philosophy. And I think particularly Plato, because it's very difficult to imagine the
所以我认为马拉松的胜利不仅给了雅典，也给了所有决定抵抗波斯入侵的希腊城市。它给了他们这样做的骨气。我也确实认为，如果雅典像米利都、埃雷特里亚那样被歼灭，那将对未来产生深远的影响。那么它的民主制度几乎会胎死腹中。它的文化影响将是巨大的。没有帕特农神庙，没有悲剧，没有修昔底德，事实上，可能没有希罗多德。希罗多德可能不会受到启发去写他的伟大历史。而且，它也会对哲学的发展产生不可估量的影响。我认为特别是柏拉图，因为很难想象
emergence of either Christianity or Islam without the legacy of Plato's influence. So to quote Walter Burkhardt in Greek religion, since Plato, there has been no theology which has not stood in his shadow for many centuries. Platonism was simply the way in which God was thought of and spoken about in the West as in the Islamic East. And so obviously that sense, the fact that Athens is going to be a crucial influence on the lands of what become the caliphate as well as on Christendom, complicates any notion of marathon, I think, as a binary conflict between Western East. And in fact, throughout these two episodes, the comparisons that we've been drawing, the modern comparison has been between Persia and America. I mean, I think America in the invading Afghanistan and in the Gulf
基督教或伊斯兰教的出现会没有柏拉图影响的遗产。所以引用沃尔特·伯克特在《希腊宗教》中的话，自柏拉图以来，没有任何神学不在他的阴影下存在了几个世纪。柏拉图主义只是西方和伊斯兰东方思考和谈论上帝的方式。所以很明显，雅典将成为哈里发国和基督教世界的重要影响，这使得马拉松作为东西方二元冲突的任何概念都变得复杂。事实上，在这两集中，我们一直在进行的比较，现代的比较一直是波斯和美国。我的意思是，我认为美国在入侵阿富汗和海湾
wars corresponds much more closely to Persia than to Athens. Agree completely. Because it's the superpower, you know, acting against rogue states on the periphery. It's for So funny that the self-image, I mean, you mentioned that the Battle of Marathon is very, very popular among American kind of commentators on the right, often, kind of historically informed commentators. But they always see themselves as the Athenians, don't they? Never as the Persians. Right.
战争中，与波斯的对应关系远比与雅典的对应关系更紧密。完全同意。因为它是超级大国，你知道，在边缘地区对流氓国家采取行动。所以很有趣的是，这种自我形象，我的意思是，你提到马拉松战役在右翼的美国评论员中非常非常受欢迎，通常是那种有历史知识的评论员。但他们总是把自己看作雅典人，不是吗？从来不是波斯人。没错。
And when George Bush talked about an axis of evil, I mean, that's language that would have meant nothing to the Athenians, but it would absolutely have meant everything to the Persians. Greece's and Athens are obviously massive, massive influences on. the West, but so too is Persia. It's just that the influence of Persia is so occluded. Surely the current president is much more a Persian figure than a Greek figure, isn't he? Yeah, it's on top of it. And I think also that the notion of it as a battle between despotism and liberty is also complicated because in due course after the defeat of the second invasion, after the great Athenian victory in the naval battle at Salamis, Athens emerges from the Persian
当乔治·布什谈到“邪恶轴心”时，我的意思是，这种语言对雅典人来说毫无意义，但对波斯人来说却意义重大。希腊和雅典显然是西方巨大的、巨大的影响来源，但波斯也是。只是波斯的影响被掩盖了。现在的总统难道不是一个更像波斯的人物，而不是希腊人物吗？是的，而且我认为将其视为专制与自由之间战斗的概念也变得复杂了，因为在第二次入侵失败后，在雅典于萨拉米斯海战中取得伟大胜利后，雅典在波斯
wars as a great power herself and as an imperial power. And many of the Greek cities who initially are freed from the great king's rule in the wake of the defeat of the Persian invasion by the Athenians end up paying tribute to Athens herself. And that is what is used to fund the Parthenon, for instance. So the Parthenon is a great symbol of the Athenian democracy, but it's also a symbol of Athenian imperialism. And there is a case for saying that perhaps Greece's would have been more peaceable had Athens been destroyed and had a kind of Pax-Persica being established, had Greece been absorbed into the Persian Empire, because the Persians knew how to run an empire. They would not have allowed the Peloponnesian War to break out and all the various other wars
战争后自己也崛起为一个大国，并成为了一个帝国。许多最初在波斯入侵失败后从大王统治下解放出来的希腊城市，最终都要向雅典纳贡。而这正是用来资助帕特农神庙的资金来源。所以帕特农神庙是雅典民主的伟大象征，但它也是雅典帝国主义的象征。有一种观点认为，如果雅典被摧毁，建立起某种“波斯治下的和平”，如果希腊被吸收到波斯帝国中，希腊可能会更和平，因为波斯人知道如何管理帝国。他们不会允许伯罗奔尼撒战争爆发，也不会允许其他各种战争。
that ended up with Greece being conquered by Macedon. Interesting. So a quick question for you. If you had to do the sort of John Rawls experiments and take your chances, you don't know what you're going to be. You don't know how rich you're going to be or where you are going to fit on the social spectrum. If you had to take your chances in Athens, or indeed in Greece generally in this period, or as a subject of the Persians, which would you choose? So if I was a Greek, I would probably opt for a Persian victory. I think my life would probably be better.
这最终导致希腊被马其顿征服。有意思。那么问你一个简单的问题。如果你必须进行约翰·罗尔斯的思想实验，去碰碰运气，你不知道自己会成为什么样的人。你不知道自己会有多富有，也不知道自己在社会阶层中处于什么位置。如果你必须在雅典，或者说在那个时期的整个希腊，或者作为波斯人的臣民去碰碰运气，你会选择哪一个？所以如果我是希腊人，我可能会选择波斯获胜。我想我的生活可能会更好。
But if I were an Athenian, I would vote for the Athenian victory because everything is in the balance for Athens. And I think that there is something heroic and noble about what the Athenians represented on the battlefield of marathon, even with the caveats that I've given. But if you were in one of the other Greek, the many other Greek cities, you would have wanted the Persians to win. So as a Greek, ignorant of what is going to come, no, I wouldn't. I would have wanted the Persians defeated. Of course I would. But looking ahead to what happens in the Pelopinnesian war and all the horrors that are constantly. on Athens' rise to greatness. I might, perhaps.
但如果我是雅典人，我会投票支持雅典获胜，因为雅典的一切都悬于一线。我认为雅典人在马拉松战场上的表现有一种英雄主义和高尚之处，即使考虑到我之前提到的那些局限性。但如果你身处其他希腊城邦中的任何一个，你可能就会希望波斯人获胜。所以作为一个对未来一无所知的希腊人，不，我不会。我本希望波斯人被打败。当然我会这么想。但展望伯罗奔尼撒战争中发生的一切，以及雅典崛起过程中不断出现的种种恐怖事件，我或许会改变主意。
I don't know. Okay. But I think none of this is to diminish, I think, the glory of what the Athenians achieved at Marathon. I think the admiration of the ages is justified. They were fighting for their liberty, if not necessarily for the liberty of Greece. And I think that their courage in going down that slope into the plain
我不知道。好吧。但我认为这并不能削弱雅典人在马拉松战役中所取得的辉煌成就。我认为千古传颂是理所应当的。他们是在为自己的自由而战，即使不一定是为整个希腊的自由。我认为他们冲下斜坡进入平原的勇气
to meet with an enemy that no Greek army had ever defeated before. I think it is, I mean, if that's not heroic, then nothing is heroic. And so I think that their victory at Marathon, even though it is reductive to cast it as the victory of the West over the East or of Europe over Asia or of freedom over despotism, I think it is a battle that is both epic and glorious. And, you know, I've found it kind of a stirring narrative since childhood. And it still stirs me to this day, I have to say. Well, people who want a rip-roaring.
去迎战一支此前从未有任何希腊军队击败过的敌人。我认为，如果这都不算英雄主义，那什么才算呢？所以我认为他们在马拉松的胜利，尽管将其简单地归结为西方对东方、欧洲对亚洲或自由对专制的胜利有些片面，但我认为这是一场既史诗又辉煌的战役。而且，你知道，我从小就觉得这是一个激动人心的故事。不得不说，直到今天它依然让我心潮澎湃。好吧，那些想要一个精彩绝伦的
dramatic retelling of that story, they could read Herodotus, but they could also read Holland in your book, Persian Fire. Or they could read both. If they had to choose one, would you recommend yourself or Herodotus? I think I'd recommend myself. I'm glad you back yourself. That's definitely the vibe of this podcast. And Dominic, of course, we've talked about the, you know, this is a battle for freedom and liberty
戏剧性重述的人，可以去读希罗多德的作品，也可以读你写的《波斯之火》。或者两者都读。如果必须二选一，你会推荐你自己还是希罗多德？我想我会推荐我自己。很高兴你对自己有信心。这绝对是本播客的风格。多米尼克，当然，我们谈到了，你知道，这是一场为了自由和解放的战斗
and it's heroic and everything. Not every war is heroic, is it? there are wars that are bogged down in mud and stalemate. Yes, next week we will be in the First World War. We'll be in 1915. So we will be in the trenches as the first gas attacks, as the first gas drifts across the battlefield, will be in the mountainous borderlands between Italy
而且它很英勇等等。并非每一场战争都是英勇的，不是吗？有些战争陷入了泥潭和僵局。是的，下周我们将进入第一次世界大战。我们将回到1915年。所以我们将身处战壕，当第一批毒气飘过战场时，我们将身处意大利与
and the Austro-Hungarian Empire for the White War. And we'll be on the beaches of Gallipoli for one of the most infamous military disasters of the 20th century. So lots to come. But Tom, thank you very much for that stirring narrative. And I remind listeners that if you want to read more about the Battle of Marathon, about Athens and Persia, there is no better place to do it than in the pages of Dan Brown's Persian fire. And I'm sure there'll be more about this in the newsletter, won't be?
奥匈帝国之间的山区边境，经历“白色战争”。我们还将来到加里波利的滩头，见证20世纪最臭名昭著的军事灾难之一。所以内容非常丰富。但汤姆，非常感谢你那激动人心的叙述。我提醒听众，如果你想了解更多关于马拉松战役、关于雅典和波斯的信息，没有比阅读丹·布朗的《波斯之火》更好的地方了。我相信时事通讯里会有更多相关内容，对吧？
Surely you'll be doing something about this in the newsletter. I imagine so. And actually, rest of history club members will be able to get lots of that First World War content. Before anybody else. Unbelievable value, isn't it? We keep saying it. All right. Thank you very much, Tom.
你肯定会在时事通讯里写点什么吧。我想是的。而且实际上，历史俱乐部成员将能够比其他人更早获得大量关于第一次世界大战的内容。这价值简直不可思议，不是吗？我们一直在说。好的。非常感谢你，汤姆。
Thank you, everybody. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hello, it's Anita again from Empire. And here's a clip from our mini-series on the extraordinary story of the Dutch East India Company in the 1600s. And it revolves around this tiny dried seed that you might have seen in your kitchens. I mean, if you've ever made a bechamel sauce or mulled wine or pumpkin pie or in India, very much used. is masala chai. I mean, a staple of every day, nutmeg is your go-to spice.
谢谢大家。再见。再见。你好，我是来自《帝国》节目的安妮塔。这是一段关于17世纪荷兰东印度公司非凡故事的迷你剧片段。它围绕着一种你可能在厨房里见过的微小干种子展开。我的意思是，如果你曾经做过白酱、热红酒或南瓜派，或者在印度，非常常用的是马萨拉茶。我的意思是，作为日常必需品，肉豆蔻是你首选的香料。
Of course masala chai's got nutmeg in it. Masala chai's got nutmeg. If it's a good masala chai, it will have cloves, nutmeg and cinnamon. You know, it was attributed, or it was credited with so many magical powers, Giles. I mean, I was looking up cure for flatulence, cure for dysentery, a hallucinogen, blood poisoning. I mean, was there anything they thought it didn't do? It did it all. It did it all. It cured the bloody flocks, as they said, the dysentery that they were all getting. But I think really, as you say, Aphrodisiac, I mean, when you're trying to sell something for vast prices, you add all these properties onto it.
当然，马萨拉茶里有肉豆蔻。马萨拉茶里有肉豆蔻。如果是一杯好的马萨拉茶，它会含有丁香、肉豆蔻和肉桂。你知道，它被赋予了，或者说被认为具有许多神奇的力量，贾尔斯。我的意思是，我查过它能治胀气、治痢疾、致幻、治血液中毒。我的意思是，有什么是他们认为它做不到的吗？它什么都能做。它治好了他们所说的“血痢”，也就是当时每个人都得的那种痢疾。但我认为正如你所说，它被视为催情剂，当你试图以高价出售某样东西时，你会给它加上所有这些属性。
And I suppose Nutmeg in the sort of 1600s was a cross between Viagra and cocaine, you know, which he mentioned earlier. And this made it extraordinary valuable, but particularly that physicians claimed it could cure the plague, the pestiferous pestilence, as it was called, which was, course, you know, cut a sway through the population of London at the time. And so they claim that if you had a bit of nutmeg, stuffed it into these bizarre nasal caps that they wore. They used to breathe through this sort of concoction of spices of which nutmeg was the key ingredient. When you go to Venice and you see those sort of beaks that they sell for Venetian outfits, that, I think, was also an anti-plague sort of nutmeg holder. You're absolutely right. Those beaks were filled with spices and it was claimed that if you breathe through those
我想17世纪的肉豆蔻就像是伟哥和可卡因的结合体，你知道，你刚才提到的。这使它变得极其珍贵，特别是医生声称它可以治愈瘟疫，也就是所谓的“致命瘟疫”，当时瘟疫在伦敦人口中肆虐。所以他们声称，如果你有一点肉豆蔻，把它塞进他们戴的那种奇怪的鼻罩里。他们过去常通过这种香料混合物呼吸，其中肉豆蔻是关键成分。当你去威尼斯看到他们为威尼斯服装出售的那种鸟嘴面具时，我想那也是一种防瘟疫的肉豆蔻容器。你说得完全正确。那些鸟嘴里装满了香料，据称如果你通过那些
spices, you wouldn't get the plague. Now obviously, it was a complete nonsense, but everyone believed it at the time. And that was the important bit because it meant that everyone wanted these spices, which meant that the prices remained extraordinarily high. And they had celebrity believers. It's why I mean, Peeps is one of those people who swore by the stuff. He said, you know, this is the only thing that saved me while others have died around me. Yeah, I mean, there's a wonderful account in my book, actually, Peeps going down to the docks are on. on a late one night and sort of doing this backhanded deal in the darkness where he shoves a few gold coins into the hands of some sea dog and in exchange he's given a small sackload
香料呼吸，你就不会感染瘟疫。现在看来，这显然是完全的胡说八道，但在当时每个人都深信不疑。这才是重点，因为这意味着每个人都想要这些香料，这意味着价格一直保持在极高的水平。而且它还有名流信徒。这就是为什么，我的意思是，佩皮斯就是那些对这东西深信不疑的人之一。他说，你知道，这是在周围人纷纷死去时唯一拯救我的东西。是的，我的书中确实有一段精彩的描述，佩皮斯在深夜来到码头，在黑暗中进行这种见不得光的交易，他把几枚金币塞进某个海员的手里，作为交换，他得到了一小袋
of nutmeg. So yeah, this was a almost black market industry was going on in London at the time. Such was the value of this spice. We hope you enjoyed that clip. Listen to the miniseries today if you did by searching Empire, World History, wherever you get your podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
肉豆蔻。所以是的，当时伦敦几乎存在着一种黑市产业。这种香料的价值就是如此之高。我们希望你喜欢这段片段。如果你喜欢，请搜索《帝国：世界历史》，在任何你获取播客的地方收听我们的迷你剧。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。